[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
dans ça vous regarde émission
exceptionnelle ce soir jean luc
mélenchon est notre grand témoin au
lendemain du 49 3 quelle est la
stratégie du président des insoumis à
l'assemblée l'opposition at-elle perdu
cette bataille des retraites le
mouvement social peut-il repartir en
pleine crise du cornât virus et quel est
le bilan du travail des insoumis dans
l'hémicycle on en parle avec lui dans un
tout petit instant sur ce plateau on
évoquera aussi la crise démocratique
qu'elle roulait populisme prospère en
europe y aurait-il une tentation
autoritaire à l'oeuvre dans le pays la
cinquième république est elle à bout de
souffle et la réponse institutionnelle
est elle la solution à la crise de la
démocratie et puis et puis nous
évoquerons aussi les primaires
démocrates américaine avec joe biden qui
crée la surprise en prenant l'ascendant
sur un bernie sanders michael bloomberg
jette l'épongé on va revenir dans le
détail sur les résultats du super
tuesday ce sera avec françois durpaire
dans qui veut prendre sa place
les primaires américaines les cartes
sont complètement rebâti dans cette
course à la maison blanche voilà jean
luc mélenchon fatah là dessus c'est
parti on y va
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
nos invités en plateau ce soir jean luc
mélenchon bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être
notre grand témoin vous présidez le
groupe de la france neuf soumises à
l'assemblée nationale vous êtes député
des bouches du rhône nous sommes
ensemble pendant une heure pour évoquer
plusieurs grands sujets d'actualité on
va parler d'abord de la réforme des
retraites
avec ce projet de loi du gouvernement
qui a donc été adoptée par le 49 3 hier
soir rejet des deux motions de censure
cette bataille des retraites stéphanie
des pierres vous nous le dire et tout à
l'heure elle est loin d'être terminée
vous suivez pour lcp ce dossier minute
par minute bienvenue à vous et puis vous
diallo gré aussi avec jean marc daniel
bonsoir et merci d'être là vous êtes
économiste professeur à escp littéraire
éditorialiste aux échos et vous avez
regardé de près le contre projet de
réforme des retraites de jean-luc
mélenchon et insoumis puisque les
insoumis ne veulent pas le statu quo ils
veulent une nouvelle réforme
on en parlera en parlera aussi je le
disais dans le sommaire de la crise
démocratique et des primaires
américaines et pour commencer
comme tous les soirs si j'ai bien
compris stéphane blakowski son billet en
forme de portrait vous allez le voir
jean luc mélenchon le vôtre tout de
suite
[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous bonsoir c'est
si j'ai bien compris ce soir si j'ai
bien compris myriam 6 jean luc mélenchon
qui nous fait l'honneur de sa présence
ce soir a tenu le coup pendant le débat
c'est parce qu'il avait une potion
magique j'ai lu ça dans libération à
chaque pause est remonté à la buvette
boire sa potion magique du cacolac
franchement vous souvenez le cacolac
c'est la boisson chocolatée qu'on donne
aux enfants pour leur goûter d'avenir et
le rendu
populaire parce qu' eelv est une
guignols marinette de papin qui lui vaut
être constamment dû qu'à connaître pour
montrer que papin avait gardé son âme
d'enfant
c'est à dire que jean luc mélenchon a
gardé son âme d'enfant pas exactement
moi je suis psychologie de bazar à fond
le gars qui boit du coca cola qui l'a
forcément gardé son âme d'enfant en fait
ça m'a surtout surpris parce que je
m'attendais pas ça moi pour moi jean luc
mélenchon c'est l'homme politique qui a
durci sa cuirasse avec des années de
combat donc de découvrir sous la
cuirasse un amateur de cas collet dont
il a gardé son âme d'enfant doit ça m'a
étonné mais je me suis rendu compte
qu'ils avaient quand même pas mal de
souvenirs qu'ils avaient de jean luc
mélenchon qui google apparaît sous un
jour assez différent finalement de
l'image qu'on a de lui généralement les
médias
quand vous parlez de son image vous
parlez de quoi de l'image dans les
sondages ah oui dans les soins là c'est
le seul indicateur qu'on est vraiment
faim serait quand on demande aux
français selon vous quelle est la
première qualité traits de caractère de
jean-luc mélenchon et dhiba
l'agressivité à 70% des français qui
trouve que jean luc mélenchon
il est agressif or quand on regarde les
débats à l'assemblée on se rend compte
que jean luc mélenchon n'est pas que
bruit et fureur parfois au contraire
c'est celui qui appelle au calme c'est
celui qui apaise on écoute
monsieur le président maintenant la
parole moi je fais partie des gens qui
souhaitent que le thon baisse
ouah n'a le droit là ont fait
redescendre on est de la présidente à
faire redescendre john holmes donc en
baisse de ton âge et ferme très d'autres
extraits autre surprise on imagine que
jean luc mélenchon quand même un esprit
partisan qui fait que quand on n'est pas
d'accord avec lui ça tourne très vite au
conflit non en fait c'est pas
systématique non plus parce que pendant
ce débat il a pris la défense de nicolas
dupont aignan un peu par pitié je sais
pas mais en tout cas c'est pas du tout
un gars qui a les mêmes idées que lui
donc voyez connaît la fameuse phrase je
ne suis pas d'accord avec ce que vous
dites mais je me battrai pour que vous
puissiez le dire est l'expression du
pontet gnangnan pense qu'il veut mais
représente le peuple français autant que
vous et moi
ah bon il est là il est élu c'est le
peuple qui l'a voulu et là le droit qu
on respecte son droit à la parole
de même que n'importe quel autre dans
cette salle puis enfin on a vu qu'on a
bien compris qu'avec avait une grosse
montée de tension sur la fin du débat
dans l'hémicycle
on imagine forcément jean luc mélenchon
fait partie de ceux qui ont rajouté de
l'huile sur le feu elle va encore une
fois pas seulement c'est vrai que c'est
un très grand orateur et quand il ou
règle votre compte ça va pas pour vous
mais si vous fait des compliments alors
là c'est très agréable c'est la
vice-présidente donc de l'assemblée qui
va féliciter et elle est républicaine
vous avez vers la science vous dirigez
les délibérations j'y reviens
naturellement d'abord je m'associe au
concert de louanges donc vous avez été
accablé et dont je ne suis pas sûr que
vous les appréciez tant que ça alors
quoi tandis républicaine c'est de l'est
républicain absolument on va finir par
croire qu'il ya deux mélenchon stéphane
c'est ça le vêtement à la tribune
il faut poser en coulisse caisse de mon
mini portraits en fait c'est là la
question c'est que la quête le goût du
conflit chez jean luc mélenchon on prend
pour un trade tempérament on voit aussi
que c'est un fake une stratégie c'est
aussi un choix de sa part il a guère
terrorisés ça s'appelle la théorie de la
conflictualité
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'il
faut pas se laisser faire en gros ça
veut dire que quand il bouscule un
journaliste que quand il apostrophe un
adversaire politique c'est pour montrer
aux gens qu'il n'y a pas de raison de
baisser la tête que le capitalisme
libéralisme n'est pas l'horizon
indépassable de notre société et que si
on veut que ça change bata son ça passe
par le conflit par la baston alors
forcément elle tribune des fois ça donne
des maux qui choisit très bien meilleur
mais parfois un peu percutant qu'on
retient donc je me souviens souvient
peut-être à marseille un tribut et la
tribune avec macroule avoir apostrophé
en disant c'est le plus grand casino fob
meilleur le soir il la croisait sur le
vieux port et alors là changement de
stratégie on n'était plus du tout dans
la conflictualité on écoute védique
c'est le plus grand dinosaure
non non ça m'étonnerait est une légère
exagération s'humanise que vous avez dit
alors du coup moi je me pose la question
de quoi pose pas la pièce doit oui ce
qu'il est vraiment ce qui complique
c'est donc ça la question que je me pose
c'est pas du tout enfin on a vu que
bernie sanders de ma part les 78
candidats se baissa donc la question de
lâcher pas du tout la question pour 2022
la question que je me pose moi c est ce
que c'est torride la préfecture alité et
toujours la meilleure pour conquérir le
pouvoir par les urnes
ou est-ce qu'au contraire il faudrait
mettre un peu de cacolac d'anciens
concepts et orrit pour vous rendre
peut-être un peu plus séduisant voilà
les ménages à une réaction vous vous
êtes assagi l'insoumis que vous êtes
s'est assagi su possible
intellectuellement non mais dans la
réaction finit par ont fini par se
transformer bien sûr dans le jeu mais
mon propos est pas de séduire
on propose c'est de convaincre pour
convaincre moi je suis porteur d'un
monde différent avec d'autres valeurs
d'autres vous pouvez pas y arriver
autrement que par la conflit tu alité
c'est-à-dire brisé l'évidence qui
évidence qui va de soi qui fait partie
de notre univers notre imaginaire il
faut le briser par là confie tu as lité
qui ouvre la conscience diar a c'est pas
évident et donc à partir de là ça y est
dans les limites du verbe de la
représentation de l'incarnation de la
roja par rapport à un autre candidat
elle s'est déjà déclarée candidate
marine le pen on a un sentiment elle
qu'elle cherche à réduire justement son
côté contestataire qu'elle cherchait à
lisser son image s'est jamais été bien
contestataires elle et c'est l'assurance
en attente c'est une stratégie longue
à l'ordre du jour et c'était moi j'ai
rien à voir avec elle donc je suis pas
concerné parce que contrairement à ce
que vous pouvez penser tout n'est pas
communication et tout n'est pas
séduction donc il faut porter des
convictions et aller jusqu'au bout si on
veut pouvoir rassembler et changer les
choses dont vous savez bon je vais pas
réduire la définition qu'on peut donner
de moi mais n'oubliez pas je suis un
partisan de la révolution citoyenne
alors d'accord ça passe par les urnes
mais c'est quand même une révolution de
l'ordre juridique un changement des
normes un changement des finalités
oui je veux transformer complètement
cette société parce que je trouve que
comme elle est là elle le vaut pas grand
chose elle est indifférente à la
souffrance alors des fois je vous cache
pas qu'il ya des foyers d effet pas
prévu par exemple la petite scène sur le
port je je je m'en mords les doigts
parce que votre collègue journaliste
était vraiment beau à rien parce que
j'interpelle à ne pas les journalistes
vers le oui ça sera pas le seul
j'interpelle le président de la
république parce que nous avions engagé
une discussion lui et moi le matin et la
discussion c'était je lui avais dit
écoutez bon les histoires voyez ce que
vous voulez que mes collègues du moi je
vous dis pas question qu'il ya un
président de la commission européenne
qu'ils soient allemands et ils me
répondent comme d'habitude c'est un
grand séducteur à vous avez tout à fait
raison du comment du tout à fait raison
mais ça tombe très bien puisque vous
l'avez sous la main la madame merkel
vous allez lui dire et le soir qu'il
arrive je lui dis alors qu'est ce
qu'elle vous dit et il me répond elle ne
lâche rien et moi non plus et ses lacs
l'otarie avec son histoire du che pas
quoi du truc qu'ils avaient avant nos
femmes et alors moi je me dis à ce
moment-là je me dis qu'est ce que je
fais je renvoie le coup et puis je me
suis dit il ya la merkel qui est
l'entrée nous regarder parce qu'on était
en mars a dit qu'elle était là et j'ai
pas envie de lui donner à voir un leader
d'opposition en train de se battre avec
le président de la république du pays
dans un bistrot à minuit il m'a semblé
que c'était une scène inconvenante
bon j'ai peut-être eu tort mais non
finalement je regrette pas je n'aurais
pas eu envie qu'elle voit ça d'ailleurs
c'est intéressant de vous voir dans
l'hémicycle à la fois justement
batailler sur sur le fond avec une
méthode on va y revenir mais en même
temps de voir que voilà vous respecter
l'institution n'a l'impression même que
vous
et ce mandat revenons retraite vous
souvenez quand même et non mais parce
que vous avez été sénateur vous avez
fait beaucoup de choses sinon voilà le
mandat de député n'est pas toujours
évident quand on est dans l'opposition
au présent qu'on ne veut plus conforme
et l'enfant il ya pas mieux c'est un
lieu quand même j'avais pu dire sacré
puisque ma personne et déjà chacun
excelle dès samedi sept autres il avait
pas pris mais oui c'est un rôle pour un
républicain l'hémicycle c'est quand même
le temple suprême
alors revenons à cette bataille des
retraites je sais pas si vous vous
rappelez
mais après les premières réformes
économiques des manuels macron notamment
les ordonnances travail et puis après il
y avait eu là la réforme de la sncf vous
aviez eu cette formule à l'endroit du
président de la république vous aviez
dit pour l'instant c'est lui qui a le
point après cette réforme des retraites
adoptée donc hier soir par 49 3 quel
point écoutez j'ai pas bien de tirer sur
les corbillards donc qui va prendre la
balle sexe il a gagné contre nous à la
sorte y venez d'être élu peut-être que
nous on avait surévalué le rapport de
forces qu'on pouvait avoir avec lui
notamment sur le code du travail et puis
on était dans un état voisin de celui
dans lequel nous a mis la sphère des
retraites parce que si vous voulez pour
notre famille politique le code du
travail la sécurité sociale
toutes ces choses là c'est les choses
essentielles vital qui nous décrit donc
à ce moment-là on pensait qu'il fallait
le prendre de plein fouet parce qu'on
sortait d'une situation extrêmement
instable la l'élection présidentielle
venait de fracasser le champ politique
donc je m'étais dit j'ai à portée de
main la possibilité d'être l'incarnation
politique de la réplique qui va venir
face du président sait pas ce qui s'est
passé et vous l'aviez revenir 23
septembre a bien marché mais les
syndicats ont été habilement cultiver
pour dire mais de quoi se mêlent semaine
en show avec ses amis la question
sociale c'est nous qui nous en occupons
très bien et ainsi de suite
bon donc on a dû lâcher prise la réforme
vous disiez oui on me voit sur la
tribune jeudi
c'est aux syndicats 2 c'est à dire que
on repasse la manche indiquant nous en
nous on se sent pas la force de mener
cette affaire-là et comme les videmment
il a eu le dernier mot et que ça s'est
passé dans des conditions pardon de le
dire mais effroyable pour nous quoi
parce que on a eu l'impression d'être
vaincus sans avoir mené vraiment de
bataille 100kg ya eu une bataille
permanente retraçant la sncf la réforme
accepter les réformes tout cas quand on
regarde et l'évolution des sondages
aujourd'hui on est dans un dans un face
à face
plus d'un français sur deux ne
comprennent pas ne soutiennent pas cette
réforme des retraites
en même temps le mouvement social
s'essouffle et le gouvernement dégaine
son 49 3 on a l'impression aujourd'hui
qu'il n'y a que des perdants dans cette
bataille
le gouvernant c'est un jour un échec
mais franchement c'est toujours un échec
d'en arriver à passer en force et le
parlement soudanais si je serais trop
bon ok moi mais bon va qu il faut qu'on
comprenne que c'est pas possible
non je pense que vous analysez très mal
cette affaire parce que tout à l'heure
je vous ai donné l'acteur nous perdons
clairement bon je dis là le point et
ensuite que fait-on après ça il faut se
réorganiser et à peine at on le temps de
se réorganiser pour changer le
dispositif de deux d'angle que arrive un
mouvement qui correspond à l'idée que je
me faisais de la situation le mouvement
des gilet jaune avant d'un coup et on
est à faire une réalité dont le contenu
certes on l'avait théorisé donc c'était
un émerveillement pour nous mais après
qu montmagny une affaire pareille c'est
à dire un mouvement insurrectionnel qui
ne veut pas de représentants qui le dit
dès le début alors comment on fait pour
à la fois exprimé politiquement style et
l'accompagner sans donner le sentiment
de le récupérer
parce que si on l'avait fait on aurait
tout fait le mouvement et puis lui même
s'est emballé ce mouvement est l'âme
vaut le président de la république a
joué le pourrissement etc
et puis
le mouvement a pris quand même un grand
coup dans la file et on en est très
attendu second comme ça ça permet
d'éclairer toute la séquence si vous
voulez arriver à comprendre ce que je
fais parce que tout ça évidemment gelé
en conscient donc à ce moment là ils ont
subi une défaite et nous avec
parce que dans ce pays c'est comme ça
quand il ya une défaite du mouvement
social le la quintessence de ce que nous
représentons politiquement prennent
prend des raclées électorale terrifiante
mai 68 10 millions de travailleurs en
grève et du derrière des élections cfm
et essorez la corolla moi je me suis
fait saurait non les européennes avec
mes amis en plus on avait peut-être
surestimé l'intérêt que les classes
moyennes de centre-ville avait pour nous
donc le bon bah ça arrive qu'est ce que
vous voulez vous menez une bataille
vous entrez pas dans le bon angle et les
choses ne se passent pas comme vous
aimeriez pardon de vous acheter un peu
mais vous avez l'impression d'avoir
gagné ce soir
alors c'est la partie sur les retraites
mais comment gagner je écouter nous
sommes 17 gouvernement pauvre insoumis
dans cet hémicycle hui à 315 marcheurs
il y a un accent 309 1 16 communiste au
total et nous qui sommes les marchands
de cette affaire nous sommes 33
nous avons mis en échec 3 115 personnes
le gouvernement le président de la
république et son doigt et il se fond
dans un 49 3 qui nous convainc personne
qui passe pour ce que c'est une
agression
et comme le premier ministre en a
visiblement par dessus la tête
au passage il a changé le dernier texte
tout en 49 3 c'est du jamais vu dans
l'histoire parlementaire pardonnez moi
mais je faire d'autre
on va voir comment vous vous êtes battus
mais on revient à ce nouveau texte
puisque vous venez de le dire ce n'est
pas exactement la copie initiale du
gouvernement qu'il était l'heure que
j'ai adopté les gens nous hier soir
treize jours où vous êtes succédé dans
l'hémicycle comment ça s'est passé
ces treize jours ils ont été auscultés
par elsa monde à occuper l'espace
saturé l'espace pour les insoumis la
réforme des retraites c'est la bataille
avec un grand l es un grand baie vous
devriez vous calmer alors tous les
moyens législatifs sont beaux absolument
tout ce qui permet naturellement dans la
dignité du débat de bloquer cette loi
nous le ferons eu 10 dès qu'il ya un
très grand nombre d'arguments c'est de
l'obstruction que j'ai participé dans ma
vie de parlementaire à plusieurs
reprises à des batailles d'obstruction
je peux vous garantir que ça n'a rien à
voir avec ce qu'on est en train de faire
mais peu importe
j'accepte le mot si ça leur fait plaisir
cela donne 23 mille amendements en
séance publique
la parole est à monsieur le président
jean luc mélenchon monsieur katona ce
mail à moteur monsieur coquerel vous
avez l'apport madame panneaux vous est
la parole mais au delà du nombre les
insoumis ont voulu démontrer qu'ils ont
travaillé le texte
le minimum pour une carrière complète
garantie chez les avocats dans leur
caisse autonome ses 1400 euros
et là vous venez fanfaronner en leur
disant qu'avec votre système plus juste
plus solidaire c'est 1000 euros ce qu'il
ya dans le texte
est ce qu'on peut entendre comme
déclaration soit ici dans l'hémicycle en
commission ou alors à la télévision et
quand on essaye de croiser les deux
honnêtement c'est pas toujours bien
clair alors là vous pourrez pas dire que
c'est paul font un
nous nous sommes pour que les gens
sachent où ils vont dans la vie la
valeur du point comment est elle définit
personne n'en sait rien quelle sera sa
valeur roman de services personne n'en
sait rien pour eux il s'agit de se poser
en adversaire privilégié de la majorité
non mais vous pouvez ricaner vous
m'impressionnez pas j'en ai déjà vu deux
hommes comme vous nous pensons même
d'ailleurs que vous est il légitime que
vous n'avez pas été élu pour cela
que cela n'était pas leur probable je
n'ai jamais dans d'autres programmes
le 49 3 à la fin du combat pour jean luc
mélenchon et ses trous je me réjouis de
l'immense écoles civique corps a été
cette lutte depuis le 5 décembre est il
va maintenant continuer dans une
guérilla populaire et parlementaire qui
va durer aussi longtemps que vous vous
obtiendrez le guérilla pas suffi donc ça
va continuer stéphane et des pierres
vous avez aimé la saison 1 il ya une
saison 2 c'est ça et où myriam parce
qu'il n'ya pas un mais deux projets de
loi retraites le premier évidemment on a
beaucoup parlé c'était le plus important
65 arctique pour définir le futur
système
le gouvernement a déclenché le 49 3
samedi il a été adopté hier mais le
deuxième lui ne contient que 5 articles
et il organise le financement du système
alors les députés planchent dessus
depuis cet après midi 15h la france est
soumise garde la même stratégie en
déposant beaucoup d'amendements alors au
total tous groupes politiques compris il
y en a environ 2000 on est quand même
bien loin des 41 milles sur le premier
projet de loi on va voir si le match
majorité opposition de gauche se rejoue
mais pour l'instant le débat se déroule
à peu près calmement objectif finir ce
deuxième projet de loi d'ici à dimanche
soir
en revanche si c'était calme dans
l'hémicycle ce matin il y a eu des gros
remous vers la commission des affaires
sociales gros remous entre socialistes
est en marche
à propos de la commission d' enquête sur
l'étude d'impact c'était vous le savez
une demande du ps qui doutent de la
sincérité de l'exhaustivité de cette
étude et ce matin-là goût la majorité a
dit niet à cette commission
officiellement pour des raisons
juridiques on écoute monique limon
député de l'isère
on ne fait pas de commission d' enquête
sur une étude d'impact on peut contrôler
on peut regarder mais ça ça a déjà été
fait par le conseil d'état ça s'est
jamais fait et c'est par monsieur à
l'eau à qui on va expliquer et faire
comprendre les procédures je pense qu'il
les connaît mieux que moi
ces procédures là je pense que c'est
encore une fois une manoeuvre politique
ça ne lui a pas plu je lui dis ça dans
mes propos mais je le pense vraiment
alors arguments juridiques qui ne
tiennent pas selon les socialistes qui
renvoie à l'accusation de manoeuvre
politique
la majorité boris vallot dénonce la
mauvaise foi des députés en marche toute
la journée hier le groupe en marche
était divisée a tergiversé pour savoir
s'il fallait ou non validée cette
fameuse commission d' enquête avant de
décider que ce serait non c'est une
décision stupide explique un pilier de
la majorité c'est une vengeance c'est
pas mal hein en tout cas les socialistes
vont contre-attaqué côté sénat ils vont
demander une commission denquête du côté
du palais du luxembourg
merci stéphane et jean luc mélenchon on
prend les mêmes et on recommence on vous
allez continuer cette guérilla voulait
dit concrètement c'est quoi c'est
nouveau des murs et d'amendements pour
qu'elle va continuer la bagarre
parlementaire avec que tous les moyens
du parlement au tombe sur des gens qui
sont quand même extrêmement confortable
à manier parce que ils sont violents
brutaux ils n'ont aucune manière ils ont
fait du marquage physique on n'avait
jamais vu ça dans un parlement n'a
publié la photo on les voit assis le
long de nos bancs pour marquer donc et
puis commettre toutes les bêtises de
l'arrogance des drh qu'ils sont ce matin
en refusant socialistes leur commission
denquête alors que c'est leur droit de
tirage
enfin ils sont parfaits mais moi pas
fait c'est vous pardon si vous permettez
mais regardez bien nous avons présenté
en commission spéciale des amendements
répétitif sur les dix sept
parlementaires insoumis pourquoi parce
que dans la commission spéciale vous
êtes appelés par votre nom et si vous
êtes présent vous défendez votre
amendement donc en effet santé beaucoup
mais quand on arrivait en séance
plénière on a redéposé les mêmes mais
vous savez vous parce que vous êtes les
premiers observateurs ya jamais eu
quarante mille amendements ce n'est pas
vrai puisqu'ils sont discutés par
paquets quand ils sont semblables
en réalité il y avait deux mille trois
cents amendements déposés 17 fois mais
qui n'ont été traitées que par marc
rendez vous remarquerez que tant le
sujet des amendes à gaza on a bien vu
que vous parler du fond sur chacun des
ralliements voilà c'est un conte est une
obstruction sur des amendements point
virgule
certes non pas ce reproche non je dis
juste que les chiffres alors moi ça
m'amuse dont la verge était mon intérêt
que l'on croit qu'ils ont été que même
crois qu'ils étaient submergés un moment
donné
une parlementaire a l'air m a raconté
qu'il y avait 700 milles sous amendement
est aussi attendu
la grande bataille parvenant des aides
sociales
notre objectif c'est de faire exploser
calendrier c'est le cas le guen est
arrivé à l'oseille calendrier de faire
exploser la république en marche on n'a
pas de ça pas trop mal marché
quand vous êtes sur ce calendrier oui
j'ai eu 33 je vous avez 300 en face de
vous qui sont capables de se renouveler
nos mythes et jour bas vous êtes obligés
d'être un peu tactique et un parlement
49,3 il vous réjouit finalement vous
avez obtenu ce que vous voulez vous les
avez acculé et ils ont ri pas ça parce
que ce n'est pas je n'aime pas qu'on
pense à ma place qu'on se met pas vrai
notre intérêt n'est pas le 49 3 et je
vais vous dire pourquoi parce que bien
sûr il ya un gain ils passent pour des
brutes et des sauvages qu'ils sont mais
le pire pour moi c'est que les jours que
j'aimais pape devant mois de combats
c'est des jours de mois de
sensibilisation parce que les gens
regardent lcp regarde nos vidéos
s'intéresse vous le savez comme moi il
ya eu un gros intérêt donc chaque jour
qui passait en engrangeait des forces en
nombre plus grande de gens convaincus
parce que tout à l'heure vous avez dit
le mouvement s'essouffle mais vous vous
trompez les gens sont toujours aussi
enragé coût probable
ils vont il y aura dix seront dans les
manifs y seront dans les marques surtout
des bulletins de vote à la parce
que je n'avais aucun autre qui les masse
travail à l'économie d'énergie donc dit
fonce comme moi petit gang c'est les
municipales l'objectif là c'est vrai
qu'on oui oui je dis à ta semaine dans
le temps moi j'invite les gens à
utiliser tous les bulletins de vote qui
trouvera il ya dessus dans dans will die
vous repère le un semis ou communiste
parce qu'en savent que ça c'est des bons
bulletins de vote qui met un bon coup
derrière les oreilles à la république
est adoptée y aura peut-être d'ailleurs
un parcours au sénat peut-être même un
autre 49,3 et c'est la 5ème république
on va en parler tout à l'heure il ya un
principe majoritaire et ce texte il a
toutes les chances d'entrer d'entrer en
vigueur on va attendre pour le savoir
vous avez jean marc daniel regarder au
fond la contre-proposition a soumises
sur les retraites
oui ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'effectivement il n'ya pas que de la
critique dans la démarche de la soumis
et des comptes proposition est donc là
je vais un peu secoué ce que vient de
dire monsieur mélenchon un choix qui a
même des évidences qu'on ne peut pas se
contenter
de dire qu'on est là pour détruire les
évidences il ya des choses qui sont des
choses en matière de retraite qui
repensent sur la démographie via un
système de retraite ça consiste à
prélever une partie du fruit du travail
des gens qui travaillent pour le
redistribuer vers des gens qui ne
travaillent plus et donc plus il ya de
gens qui travaillent plus c'est facile
moi il ya des gens qui travaillent et
puis il ya des gens qui sont à la
retraite plus c'est difficile il faut
alors simplement juste à voir je vous
dirais la façon dont on prélève
c'est-à-dire par répartition par
capitalisation on prélève sur des gens
qui travaillent juste pour vous rappeler
que vous étiez membre d'un gouvernement
fait vous avez rejoint gouvernement à
l'époque de monsieur jospin qui venait
d'adopter le rapport charpin qui
rappelait cette c'est évident c'est à
dire que dans le rapport charpin qui
devait fédérer un peu les opinions sur
la retraite et que le premier ministre
avait adopté il y avait bien dit qu'il
fallait retarder l'âge de départ à la
retraite et augmenter la durée de
cotisation est cassée j'ose pas rien
merci non il ne fait rien il a créé un
fonds pour faire face au creux des mots
grande réserve ce fonds il ya 32
milliards aujourd'hui
il a créé un fois en capitalisation
alimentée par la csg pour essayer alors
si vous voulez avoir un peu de temps
pour essayer de débats sur la question
du contre projet qu'est ce qu'ils
proposent la croyance sur ce corps trop
plongé à deux mesures phares le retour à
l'âge de départ à la retraite à 60 ans
et 40 annuités de cotisation pour
pouvoir partir à la retraite et en face
de ses mesures phares qui coûte
il y a deux idées là aussi assez
importante la première c'est qu'il n'y a
pas de raison de bloquer le montant des
retraites en part de pub à 14% on peut
dépenser plus ce qui serait une
originalité parce qu'avec 14 % nous
sommes déjà au delà de la plupart de nos
pays des pays comparables il ya que
l'italie qui fait plus et l'allemagne et
le japon par exemple qui sont des pays
que vous chérissez l'allemagne et le
japon qui sont débarqués en tout cas
sont plus vieux que nous
qui sont ces lieux connus ou en consacre
10% de leur pub à la retraite
et comme ils sont heureux vous avez
remarqué quand ils sont pas si mal rocks
voilà il ya quelque 13 millions de
pauvres chez eux et notamment celle sur
la deuxième mesure consiste à augmenter
la base taxable cdja la masse salariale
et vous proposer une augmentation des
salaires en augmentant notamment les
salaires des femmes pour les ramener à
la parité et en augmentant les salaires
les plus bas
or je pense que dans la situation de
l'économie actuelle une augmentation de
salaire se traduirait par davantage de
chômage
la dernière commission chargée
d'examiner l'évolution du smic le
dernier rapport qu'elle a fait a bien
indiqué que si on donnait le coup de
pouce au smic qu'on allait aggraver la
situation de l'emploi je vous rappelle
1% ou de deux coups de pouce s'évaluent
entre 15000 et 30 mille chômeurs est
dans la situation de notre rapport offre
demande nous avons un déficit commercial
de 60 milliards d'euros
sa clause la source de la retraite non
messieurs les salaires également la
sauterelle et l'hiver nucléaire qui
peuvent être imputés aux distributions
de revenu et ses orientations à ce
problème dans l'orne monsieur mélenchon
donc la retraite à 60 ans mais en gros
fait plus d'emplois et un déficit
commercial qui se creuse parce que vous
augmentez le smic nommons le dire vous
18 mois l'emploi c'est moins de la
pardonnez moi c'est plus de chômage avez
vous oublié l'hiver nucléaire
on n'a pas la même prémices et ça se
voit assez simplement le point de départ
ce n'est pas le nombre de personnes qui
travaillent par rapport à ceux qui ne
travaillent plus le point de départ
c'est combien aux produits et comment on
partage cette production car un
travailleur aujourd'hui produit trois
fois plus qu'il ya 20 ans par conséquent
comment est répartie cette quantité
nouvelles de richesse au moment où elle
sort ou comment dire elle sort de
l'entreprise elle rentre en produits
vendus d'accord voilà ça c'est la
question de fond la proportion de la
répartition entre capital et travail
elle a été à un moment donné 2
60 40 elle est de 70 32 que nous disons
nous c'est navrant tepa des usines à gaz
augmenter les salaires si vous augmentez
les salaires vous augmenter les
cotisations un point donne deux
milliards et demi d'augmentation de
salaire évidemment l'augmentation de
salaire elle va être prise sur le
bénéfice
c'est bien sur quoi ça va être pris donc
dû proposons comme point de départ pour
alimenter les régimes de retraite
d'améliorer la répartition entre capital
et travail et nous faisons remarquer
modifier le chercheur s et voilà bon nom
ne dira pas la merde avec le même mot
tous les deux mais oui de vous en
prendre un morceau pour nous voilà elle
c'est pas la première fois qu on fera ça
parce que je vais faire deux remarques
rapide
la première le temps travaille depuis le
début du siècle précédent a été divisée
par pratiquement par deux et donc la
moitié de cette diminution du temps de
travail nécessaire a été répartie entend
libérer c'est à dire qu'une partie du
travail gratuit que produit le salarié
car j'espère que tout le monde a bien
compris que le capitalisme ça fonctionne
c'est le travail gratuit
il paye une paye et puis le reste c'est
pour lui bon et vous continuez à
produire pendant ce temps là une partie
la moitié a été réparé à y gagner
alors ça donne la baisse du temps de
travail dans la journée dans la semaine
dans l'année et dans la vie ça c'est
notre ligne à nous depuis un siècle et
demi ici alors permettre d'intervenir
surpris c'est que vous avez tout à fait
raison
les gains de productivité qui aurait été
qu'ils ont permis la croissance en
améliorer le pouvoir d'achat et le temps
sauf qu'il y en a plus de gains de
productivité en ce moment l'économie
française oui ne fait plus guère quant à
l'or et les mêmes en situation
probablement cette année de recul et est
d'ailleurs la preuve de ce que vous
dites c'est que quand il y avait des
gains de productivité envoyé le medef se
proposait de les partager
ce n'est jamais le bon moment il ya des
gains de productivité il faut faire des
économies il ya plus de gains de
productivité il faut faire des économies
nous n'avons jamais droit à rien que
nous n'allions chercher de la
productivité au total
je veux terminer par rapport à votre
raisonnement qui a la forme d'une
cohérence laissez-moi exploser la
cohérence du mien réalise déjà vous avez
fait des comparaisons internationales
vous auriez pu à la faveur de vos
compatriotes faire remarquer qu'un
ouvrier français produit en 1h 20 % de
plus qu en anglais donc normalement on
pourrait partager les 20%
supplémentaires entre les uns et les
autres si on est en compétition avec les
anglais avec les allemands pareil les
travailleurs les plus productifs du
monde
ça paraît incroyable c'est cette bande
de feignants de français qui passent
leur temps en vacances à la retraite et
le reste la france et je j'insiste sur
ce point est en un temps si tuation de
performance alors évidemment comme la
part de l'industrie et comme la part des
activités productives de cette nature en
b c est que dans les services les gains
de productivité sont très faibles
vous êtes seulement en train de
constater que comme les services
occupent la place qu'occupait autrefois
le travail industriel et agricole
les gains de productivité sont plus bas
voilà c'est tout point avec vous pouvez
pas vous en prendre aux travailleurs
français de ça je finisse avec votre
permission le peuple français
globalement guilly moins que les autres
mais il vieillit alors qu'à longue faire
quelle est la solution
si nous ne répartit sont pas ceux que la
machine et l'intelligence artificielle
peuvent libérer temps de travail et de
richesses pour le répartir en temps
libre mais qu'est ce que vous voulez
faire d'autres vous à l'esclavagisme la
poignée qui restent au travail ou bien
condamnée à la misère absolue
ceux qui ne peuvent plus travailler vous
êtes bien obligés de partager qu'on va
être je ferai juste de repartir mais je
suis bien déçu de ne pas vous avoir
convaincus aussi tôt oui la première
marque c'est sur la situation de
productivité de l'économie française les
lié au fait qu'il ya beaucoup de chômage
en france est ce qui fait que toute une
partie de la population qui dans les
autres pays et en emploi est au chômage
et donc il ya une partie l'emploi peu
qualifié qui existe dans les autres pays
qui n'existe pas en france et le
deuxième élément c'est que véritable
enjeu effectivement c'est vrai partir de
la richesse je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec vous seulement il faut la créer
cette richesse chat c'est incroyable le
plus c'est bien connu alors voilà que
mélenchon arrive on crée rien et puis en
plus il veut partager on en crée pas
assez pour payer des retraites puisque
le système est déjà en déficit
et si on alourdit les contrevenants
premièrement les gens des déficits non
pardon mais je marche je m'intéresse à
la halle cohérent d'une pensée je ne
suis pas d'accord pour dire que le
système est en déficit le corps dit
qu'ils ont entre 5 et 15 milliards et
vous qu est un économiste quand même
vous trouvez normal une évaluation ou le
trou est prévue ça n'est pas sérieux
y'a pas afficher tient un verre est un
problème de déficit et d'urgence à le
combler alors bien déficit constaté en
2019 le régime général de la branche
vieillesse était un déficit d'un peu
plus d'un milliard d'euros et ce déficit
va s'aggraver rire vous dites un peu
plus d'un milliard en 2010 un milliard
c'est même pas un trait de crayon et 312
milliards de la sécurité de 2,2 l'an
vous mettra pas d'accord sur cette
question à la fois de vos commentaires
il ya une logique hôtel est construite
et cohérente y en a une autre celle un
autre et on ne part pas démarqué au jeu
de ce direct avec jean luc mélenchon je
voulais vous montrer un petit sujet
maintenant présent sur le style insoumis
dans l'hémicycle parce que il a tout
chamboulé la vie parlementaire regardez
c'est signé mais était vraiment il ya
presque trois ans 17 ans soumis débarque
à l'assemblée alors il y a ceux qui ne
se connaissent pas encore
loïc de la troisième la gérante et
et puis il y aller tête d'affiche c'est
un tel bonheur de les voir là bonjour
monsieur le député monsieur
ensemble ils forment une équipe de choc
et combien imposer leur marque de
fabrique
on commençait de poing gauche ou pas je
suis la parole en devenant officielle
dans un hémicycle se transforme et elle
prend tout d'un coup des ailes elle a
une portée
elle a un sens on ne parle jamais en
vain dans un hémicycle parlementaire on
ne vote jamais enlever votre parole
madame la ministre ne vont absolument
rien et la parole ils la prennent
d'abord en commission juste est ce qu'il
serait possible même la présidente
d'avoir un état des lieux du nombre
d'amendements nous avons traité
jusqu'ici nous n'avions vu 77 d'accord
avec un taux d'acceptation 0% dans un
évidemment et puis surtout dans
l'hémicycle avec de nombreux coups
décrit serez-vous le premier disque d'un
gouvernement au service des nouveaux
riches qui fabrique des nouveaux pauvres
quant aux commissions pour ça qu elles
sont à votre disposition vous ne fait
qu'un seul geste en direction du peuple
vous le bâillonner vandelli sf d'abord
[Musique]
ça c'est pour la forme mais les insoumis
c'est aussi 50 4214 amendements déposés
depuis 2010 est au total 112 ont été
adoptés c'est aussi sur les textes des
autres qu'on les entend toujours prêt à
défendre leurs idées pour mieux
s'opposer à la majorité aujourd'hui
notre collègue est droite mais moi je
m'en fiche qu'ils soient de droite du
centre du sud de l'est de l'ouest
peu importe notre collègue aurélien
pradié propose d'élever un peu leur
statut vous le dis madame la ministre je
pensais que sur ce point là
l'allongement en cas de décès d'un
enfant de 5 à 2 jours n'y aurait pas de
france insoumise et il y aurait pas de
républicains il y aurait pas de modem il
n'y aurait pas de en mars mais
finalement c'est quoi le style de la
france insoumise pour les autres députés
pour moi leur style c'est un style c'est
le style de la rue et c'est un style
très violent y a pas de style
particulier ils sont parfois force de
proposition également mais en tout cas
ils n'ont pas été depuis quelques temps
c'est souvent malheureusement au
détriment du fond parce que c'est des
batailles de slogans là au contraire il
faudrait parfois avoir des explications
je sais pas s'il ya un style et les
filles parce que finalement il ya autant
de styles qui lie à députés à la france
1 / mise en fait le entre françois
ruffin corbières coquerel matile panneau
je vais pas les énumérer tous ils ont
ils sont chacun dans un style qui leur
appartient donc c'est bien pour ça c'est
pas un moule voilà d'autres invités nous
ont rejoints sur ce plateau pour aborder
la question institutionnelle la crise
démocratique bonsoir richard wehrli mais
vous allez réagir vous inquiétez pas je
vous présente simplement les invités qui
sont après dents parmi nous richard qui
est chroniqueur dans cette émission et
qui est le corps soins dans parisien du
quotidien suisse le temps et vincent
martini bonsoir à vous êtes professeur
de sciences politiques à nice et à
polytechnique
membre du comité de la rédaction du
journal le 1 qu'on a beaucoup ici à lcp
vous avez signé un essai notamment
l'année dernière
passionnant sur le retour du prince
était aux éditions flammarion joaillier
sourire on sent que vous êtes très fier
de vos de vos ouailles on va revenir sur
ce sujet
voilà vous avez commenté les bons points
on s'enquiert il ya un côté voilà chef
de troupe en même temps au service de
quoi beaucoup de coups d'éclat qu'est ce
que vous avez fait voter dans cet
hémicycle made in la france insoumise
estampillé des insomnies quoi des
milliers de propositions sous forme
d'amendement trois niches tiendra la 3e
niche parlementaire c'est la troisième
fois qu'on va présenter un ensemble de
projets sur le fou parce que vous avez
vous dire que vous avez par exemple sur
les niches parlementaires c'est vrai que
vous avez permis notamment aux
républicains sur les questions de
handicap de de faire naître un vrai
débat qui aboutit à une forme
d'unanimité le moment venu avec la
majorité mais en votre nom vous avez des
textes à faire valoir qu'ils ont pu être
votée mais vous faites quoi d'habitude
vous nous suivez ou pas oui des dizaines
vous l'avez vu tous les textes qui ont
été présentés dans les niches mais nous
sommes l'opposition donc en général mais
la règle c'est qu'on est battu et en
plus on n'a pas des gens spécialement
tolérant ouvert en face de nous donc on
est battu mais on fait vivre un débat
ont fait des propositions on oblige à
décentrer le les centres d'intérêts
habituel la république en marche c'est
très simple il vote contre nous depuis
cinq minutes après ils déposent en fait
sur le même thème
donc parce que nous sommes dans
l'hémicycle ce qui exprime une forme de
sensibilité à ce qui se passe dans la
société qui est en notre arme en plus
grande que celle de la majorité
donc le travail accompli est magnifique
et puis vous savez la vie parlementaire
c'est des propositions que vous
présentez alors les gens se disent ah
bah tiens je suis d'accord avec eux ou à
non je suis pas d'accord avec eux de
vous faites vivre le débat dans le pays
et puis vous représenter des gens qui se
sentent représentés par nous quand ils
nous écoutent d'apparat je suis bien
d'accord mais à terme options si ton
face à la chronique de retard que je
vends bien compris la question parce que
vous présentez des textes mais ne sont
pas adoptées parfois je l'avais réussi à
mobiliser réussir à 17
sur les retraites le gouvernement a
repris quelques uns de leurs amendements
certes la majorité mais ça vous fait pas
un petit pincement après tout les
communistes demandent le rejet comme
vous du texte sur les retraites mais au
final il joue quand même un petit peu de
jeu et ils enrichissent ce texte
vous ne regrettez pas ça alors bien sûr
que je le regrette et je cours me pendre
en sortant de votre style mais quel
sérieux pour être sérieux moi je suis
enchanté de ce que font mes camarades
communistes on travaille tous les jours
ensemble mais je voudrais faire juste
remarquer que la majorité avec nous si
épris d'une manière radicale ils ont
éliminé avant même qu'on discute
classé comme rejeté 315 amendement de
d'aisance ou me considérait comme hors
sujet à 40 ans hors sujet 40 annuités de
cotisation on suggère exemple considéré
que tout ce qu'ont proposé était hors
sujet et que le seul sujet intéressant
c'était eux et la possibilité pensait-il
de nous ridiculiser en ne laissant que
des amendements j'en conviens de
suppression ou de formes qui pour nous
était comme vous l'avez vous même admis
tout à l'heure l'occasion de parler tout
est à dire on a parlé de tout ce qu'ils
ont fait exprès des cartes et aux
amendements garder les comédies mais ils
sont pris les pieds dans le tapis une
fois de plus parce que du coup ils
n'étaient pas préparés ils le disent eux
mêmes il avait scindé entre walt est
qu'ils avaient trois rapporteurs
mais on discutait jamais de ce qu'ils
avaient prévu au moment prévu donc on
discutait au début de l'article 65
et puis on a discuté à l'article 8 de ce
qu'ils se trouvent
oui on les a perdus on les a on a fait
ce qu'il fallait pour les disperser et
par français avec nos arguments nos
corps de deux batailles de changer de
focale ce 49,3 ce passage en force
comment le regarde depuis l'étranger
alors il y a quelque chose qui était
hors sujet pour jean luc mélenchon hier
soir dans l'hémicycle c'est la
démocratie
vous l'avez dit on va l'écouter vu de
l'étranger vous serez dès demain matin
la risée du monde civilisé démocratique
oui parfaitement les grands rénovateurs
ou ailleurs qu'en france est sous votre
gouvernement
une loi aux contenus inconnus aux
dispositions inconnu et réécrite par
l'exécutif tout seul avant d'être
adoptée sans vote
dans quel autre pays une chose pareille
est elle possible
il ya dire que la question posée par
jean luc mélenchon est une bonne
question est d'ailleurs les
commentateurs étrangers qui regarde la
france
ils ont retenu que le 49-3 ce n'est
quand même pas tout à fait démocratique
alors je vais citer quelques exemples il
y a d'abord le soir de bruxelles qui
parle d'un muselage l'opposition a été
muselé le débat aussi il est à la
télévision publique allemande qui dit
que faire passer une loi sans
l'approbation du parlement est
définitivement un geste antidémocratique
il y a le quotidien toujours allemand
tageszeitung selon lequel le coup porté
au régime parlementaire est rude
alors il y en a qui sont un petit peu en
retrait c'est un pays de grande
tradition parlementaire c'est le royaume
uni et le guardian pour lequel en fait
ce n'est pas très étonnant le pouvoir
exécutif s'est contenté de contourner le
parlement
on n'est pas tout à fait dans la risée
on est plutôt dans le fatalisme cynique
au monde ancien monde même combat mais
parce que voilà les européens ils
connaissent la france
et souvenez-vous de cette fameuse
couverture de the economist où on voyait
le président sarkozy à l'époque l'un
avec un chapeau de napoléon lien entre
la voie vingtaine pourquoi le dit
économie se montrer cela c'est parce
qu'il voulait dire que tout en france
dépend du président et quand le
président pour une raison ou pour une
autre est empêchée eh bien ça ne marche
pas il y a aussi le site de conversion
qui est un site universitaire qui disait
la personnalisation du pouvoir ne
changera pas elle demeurera parce
qu'elle est constitutive de la vème
république
et il cite et vous savez cette phrase
des manades macro à propos de la sphère
benalla quand il vise au journaliste
venait me chercher bien on a un peu
l'impression que quelque part emmanuel
macron a dit à jean luc mélenchon venait
me chercher alors il ya quand même un
partisan étranger d' emmanuel macron
c'est le chancelier l'ancien chancelier
allemand gerhard schröder qui dans un
entretien à die continuer mais alors
pour vous auteur du hareng 2 bis
j'imagine c'est une occasion de
surenchérir une réaction
l'élégance particulière de quelqu'un qui
nous regardent de l'étranger veut pas
trop nous offense et c'est qu'on passe
vraiment pour une bande de blizzard
n'existe pas un traitement pareil alors
bon moi j'aime pas trop qu'on se moque
de mon pays et c'est anglais feraient
bien de réfléchir et faire des
caricatures mais je suis bien obligé de
dire que on vraiment on a un
comportement dont nos compatriotes en
fusion finissent par pu se rendre compte
qu'ils sont mithridate ise alors après
dix ans à la décharge des français que
de toute façon le problème de la
personnalisation existe maintenant même
dans les régimes parlementaires du fait
de la circulation des réseaux sociaux
etc
raison de plus pour se prémunir par des
méthodes institutionnel de l'abus de
pouvoir que représente ce que dit le
président qui rétrécit vous pensez qu'on
assiste à un concert est restée au sein
d'un instant mais moi je n'ai pas trouvé
que sarkozy aurait trait cissé il était
de droite il faisait son boulot c'est
anglaise emma via l'impertinent alors
macron ils essaient c'est l'homme du
capital financier fait son travail mais
il ne faisait pas une valeur d'un
système républicain peut porter avait
dit qu'il l'a dit il dit script terai
les institutions peut-être oui mais tout
seul c'est leur caractéristique à tous
ces types c'est que l'on considère que
l'alpha et l'oméga c'était alors le
peuple a dans la peau de place et ils
sont dans l'esprit du fondateur mais le
fondateur charles de gaulle c'est
l'homme qui est un résultat d'une
histoire incroyable pour les français
d'une chance inouïe d'avoir sauvé la
face après un désastre comme celui de la
déroute
et puis il arrive à la fin d'une période
catastrophique où il faut des colonisés
et donc son rôle particulier à ce moment
là les instruments qu'il demande ne doit
pas être prolongé plus que ça et puis
quand même depuis cinquante années de la
constitution a été changé vingt fois le
groupe france est inchangée au public au
moins quatre points d une constituante
faire en sorte qu'on sorte de l'hyper
concentration des pouvoirs dans les
mains d'un seul homme vous l'avais dit à
de nombreuses reprises vous l'avez faire
une cour du même genre une enseigne
l'adjudant vincent martinez vous allez
nous dire
d'ailleurs vers quel régime votre coeur
balance mais partons de cette crise de
la démocratie parce que on la retrouve
partout à faire gréve on nous parle de
crise de la démocratie crise des gilet
jaune crise de la démocratie
les populismes aux portes du pouvoir
quand il ne gouverne pas déjà crise de
la démocratie c'est votre diagnostic
prenez vous en cas vous chez vous les
journalistes qui dit tchad ou bouts de
chandelles et pas d'imagination
il ya une crise du gouvernement
représentatif
il ya une crise de la démocratie des
élus il ya une crise finalement de la
confiance envers la manière dont les
élus dirige les différents pays
démocratiques c'est ce que révèle
notamment les différentes vagues de
baromètre de la confiance du cevipof
centre de recherches politiques de
sciences po qui tous les ans évalue la
confiance des citoyens dans les
institutions
qu'est ce qu'ils nous disent à 85 % des
sondés disent les hommes politiques ne
se préoccupent pas des gens comme nous
et en même temps il n'y a pas de crise
de la démocratie parce que le soutien
dans le régime démocratique lui-même il
est encore extrêmement élevé bon encore
une fois plus de huit français sur dix
se disent oh la démocratie c'est le
meilleur des aspirations pas
d'aspirations un régime autoritaire
enfin il ya une aspiration qu'à peu près
d'un tiers des français qui pensent que
si on élisait un homme fort on pourrait
suspendre la démocratie mais c'est à peu
près le même taux partout en europe on
pourra dire c'est une crise mais si on
regarde les dix des quinze années ça n'a
pas beaucoup évolué en revanche ce qu'on
constate c'est qu'il ya cette espèce de
distance progressif qui existe entre les
citoyens et les élus
et cette distance elle est ce lui aussi
d'une revendication d'une horizontalité
et d'une participation c'est à dire que
les citoyens ne se contentent plus d'une
certaine manière d'accepter que la
démocratie soit uniquement
le moment de l'élection et qu' il
devrait se taire ou alors observer la
vie politique comme un jeu entre les
élections ce qu'il revendique c'est de
participer et non pas d'en être les
spectateurs c'est ça je crois la
nouvelle alors comment on les associe
les citoyens la démocratie comment on
fait mieux fonctionner la démocratie
d'abord vous venez bien de résumer la
situation c'est à dire que les gens le
peuple sait que la démocratie c'est son
affaire que c'est le moyen pour lui
d'être présent il n'y a pas de désaveu
on n'est pas dans une période où les
gens disent ras-le-bol de tout ça amenez
nous un guide un conducteur en général
je sais pas quoi non c'est pas leur
ligne et en même temps ils ont le
sentiment d'abord fondamentalement juste
que tout ça c'est du vent
pourquoi parce que à la fin vous tombez
toujours sur l'économie de services qui
vous dire monsieur mes enfants très
sympathique mais les retraites on ne
peut rien il faut serrer la vis c'est à
dire que le lait la classe dominante
réussi à faire passer ce qu'elle croit
juste pour une loi de la nature qu'on ne
peut pas le changer et les gentils mais
c'est quand même curieux ça fait 40 ans
que ça dure le chemin de ma personne n'y
peut rien on a parlé quand même des
questions et connaître les retraites
mais sur comment on la répare cette
démocratie comment on fait on sorte que
les gens du show santé représente
il ya deux choses à bouger les
institutions et système médiatique les
institutions de manière à arriver à
combiner la stabilité parce qu'on ne
dirigera jamais un pays de 65 millions
d'habitants à une grande puissance en
assemblée générale permanente il faut
quand même être sérieux on a besoin
d'institutions stables et de mécanismes
de pouvoir connue et dont le
fonctionnement peut-être à tout moment
observé
bon et puis en même temps on a besoin de
permettre au peuple surtout les nôtres
qui est un peuple ça fait 1500 ans que
ça dure qui sont comme ça en rigolant
réfractaires dépistage pourrait remonter
jusqu'aux gaulois parce que ça a très
mal commencé le jour même où ils ont élu
vercingétorix la moitié foutez le camp
et voulait plus obéir donc c'est vous
dire que ce qu'il faut bien soupapes
il faut pas des soupapes mais un moyen
pour le peuple d'intervenir c'est pas le
peuple par danger donc on fait je suis
plein grès qui permettent les
référendums
vos catoire les référendums d'initiative
citoyenne c'est à dire où l'initiative
populaire lui permet quand il a le
sentiment que le pouvoir ne fait pas son
travail de donner la direction et dire
on va faire comme ça et pas autrement
voilà ce qu'on voulait c'est urgent de
la social citoyen oui c'est aux gens
tout cas il ya une demande qui est fait
dans ce sens que je crois qu'il ya un
peu deux dimensions cette question la
première c'est les outils probablement
la création d'un régime mixte entre le
régime représentatif qui sera rénové
mais aussi un régime de démocratie plus
directe ça peut être le tirage au sort
ça peut être les assemblées citoyennes
ça peut être le référendum révocatoire
aux citoyens qui existe d'ailleurs dans
beaucoup de démocratie et pas seulement
en sus la suisse de vivre chars vers
l'avant tout cas par exemple il ya ce
première question délai l'osm avec
soumise au peuple
la scène et ont des outils mais y'a
comme l'attendait c'est important pardon
monsieur 2 0 mais ce que dit cet homme
là ça montre que c'est possible je suis
sont pas des barbares qui sont en état
des mots de permanents chaque fois que
je parle de référendum d'initiative
citoyenne revo 14
ça va être la pagaille tous les jours la
question des outils mais à une deuxième
question c'est la question la
personnalisation vous disiez tout à
l'heure que la personnalisation ne va
pas s'arrêter il me semble que là quand
on en a déjà discuté ensemble que c'est
probablement une des contradictions dans
lequel vous pouvez vous trouver prix
c'est-à-dire le désir d'une
horizontalité d'une constituante et en
même temps une personnalisation dont
vous même n'êtes par exemple y compris
dans votre mouvement et puis des
critiques qui vont avec c'est à dire la
critique d'autoritarisme ou de
verticalité et donc c'est vraiment une
question qui se pose je crois à tous les
mouvements politiques c'est à dire
comment est ce qu'on arrive à
réconcilier d'un côté ce désir
d'horizontalité et en même temps cette
espèce de maladies de la
personnalisation et de l'incarnation qui
est le produit des institutions
évidemment mais qui dont il s'agit un
peu de s'émanciper ou de trouver des
alternatives
on pourrait dire il ya un canasson c'est
par contre c'est par des institutions
vous avez raison qu'il ya une
contradiction puisque nous sommes
conduits par la forme même du système à
devoir incarner d'accord mais on n'est
pas forcément candidat le faire au
départ mais on comprend que c'est par là
que ça passe comme disait mon mon
compère françois delapierre autrefois
ils disent on a écrit des dizaines de
bouquins passionnant tous les deux mais
ça
intéressé personne sauf qu'à partir du
moment où on a commencé à monter sur les
tables et a pu respecter la règle du jeu
là oui ça on a commencé à avoir de
l'écho de bon c'est pour dire qu' il ya
une part de théâtralité qui rentre dans
toute action politique et c'est bon que
les affects font partie des chemins de
la condition c'est moi qui vous le dit
qui est dit le contraire étant plus
jeune qui ne croyait car on les mas le
parti révolutionnaire et je ne sais quoi
d abstraction qu'ils n'avaient aucune
réalité dans la vie des gens les affects
font partie des chemins de conditions
mais on ne peut pas s'en contenter
sinon ça devient de la manipulation donc
c'est la stabilité des institutions et
la culture démocratique commune qui
permet de faire vivre une démocratie
mais surtout c'est que le peuple est
vraiment le pouvoir il ne l'a pas et
continuellement matin midi et soir
les grands médias sont là pour répéter
que de toute façon il n'ya qu'une seule
possibilité en seul chemin gerry's nom
et derna
on disait moi je me disais pas que dans
votre fonctionnement de votre parti vous
ne faites pas élire les dirigeants de
votre parti vous considérez que le front
de gauche c'est un super mauvais
souvenir tout le monde qui se disputent
pour être avoir une place mieux vaut et
on est plus efficace avec un chef et un
groupe décidé jamais de la vie c'est que
comme ça les intéresse pas de regarder
ce qui se passe vraiment par exemple
nous nous servions s'il n'a pas été lu
par exemple mais bien sûr que si mais
paris mais par ceux qui étaient sur la
plateforme à qui on a proposé la liste
des gens ils pouvez cocher dedans et ils
ont voté de la même manière que moi j'ai
été élu par le groupe ici je n'ai aucune
autorité dans le mouvement sinon moral
mais je n'ai aucun pouvoir sur moi qui
décide
ceux qui ont fait des procès en
démocratie à notre mouvement comme
personne n'a été regardée si ce qu'il
disait était vrai ou pas incroyable s'il
suffit qu'il y en ait un qui râlent ce
sont les ratés de la plus aimée des
critiques en interne et qui seront qui
ont été publiés voilà et wii puis y est
passé on se le demande pour ces
personnes et fait des histoires non mais
c'est pas sérieux comme boulot
cephas sérieux ce que vous faites là
mais vous prenez un gars et moi je lui
dirai lui tient qu'à vous paierez votre
percepteur la voulez mais pas si les
brutales bons vont vous avez des gens
qui sont des ratés de l'élite de
l'investiture
nous avons fait un comité d'investiture
tirés au sort combien de partis font ça
tirait au sort mesdames messieurs
et ils ont écouté 600 candidats dans
lequel moi j'avais 599 ami personnel
donc je me suis tenu à distance pour
prendre pas chèque tout le monde et le
comité a choisi ceux qui n'ont pas été
choisis ont immédiatement protesté de
quoi les mêmes qui me demandait à moi de
les nommer il aurait voulu que moi je
leur dise plus toi toi toi t'as petit
chef
je ne le ferai pas ni signe aux cardons
madame vous êtes témoins ici du fait
qu'on m'a demandé de faire la police
politique dans mon groupe parce que des
gens ne parlent pas de la même manière
ne disent pas les mêmes choses que moi
je ne les ai jamais fait je crois à la
liberté je crois à l'autorégulation
c'est un pari fou à mon âge de faire ça
mais j'y crois et voyez-vous quoi ça
marche bon écoutez on va s'arrêter là on
aurait pu continuer un peu plus
longtemps ce débat passionnant mais je
voulais absolument vous faire réagir sur
ce qui est en train de se jouer au sein
de la primaire démocrate américaine des
primaires qui au fond créé complètement
la surprise les cartes sont rebattues et
le grand vainqueur
c'est lui écoutez la je suis ici pour
vous dire que nous sommes complètement
vivant il ne vous y trompez pas cette
campagne va renvoyer donald trump chez
lui et tout de suite qui veut prendre sa
place avec françois durpaire
[Musique]
bonsoir françois alors on le croyait
hors course
et revoilà buydens exactement c'est le
come back l'un des plus impressionnants
de l'histoire on dit toujours là
vraiment c'est le cas il a à gagner dans
tous les états du sud et il a même en
nombre de délégués m'attendais pas c'est
bernie sanders
vous avez peut-être entendu les images
où il crée victoire et y confronte vous
allez voir on a vu des images de bans en
haut et on va regarder ça au fait voici
ma petite soeur valérie et ma femme
villes aux noms elles ont changé de
place voici ma femme
et voici ma soeur elles ont échangé leur
place voilà c'est la céréale et voilà by
donne c'est ça donc il fait il en fait
une tous les jours donc là il confond sa
soeur et sa femme c'est l'homme quand
même qu'elle était capable de dire
j'adore revenir dans le vert menthe il
était dans le nyong shy bon s'est il bon
on se dit et ce qu'il va pouvoir
représenter le parti
en tout cas il ya un certain nombre
d'atouts très claire la première c'est
qu'il a montré une sociologie du vote
il a effectivement les afro américains
mais il a gagné dans des banlieues il a
gagné dans des zones rurales dont qu'il
a il a quand même élargi son électorat
s'est pas uniquement l'électorat
afro-américain et puis il va bénéficier
du report des voix des autres centristes
parce qu'il a vraiment un boulevard et
notamment la nouvelle du jour ça c'est
fini
beumer que ces quatre délégués quatre
délégués 400 millions de dollars
investis dans le super tuesday ça fait
100 millions de dollars le délégué ça
fait cher quand même pour l'élection et
il se retire de la course mais vous vous
rappelez da phrase de il avait dit je
suis là pour dépenser des millions pour
battre donald trump et la fin de la
phrase pour battre bernie sanders un
hameau du coup on en est ou sebha y
donne le favori sanders c'est fini alors
aujourd'hui évidemment il ya pas mal
d'atouts pour bayonne parce qu'il va y
avoir une élection 10 une élection 2007
il est très en tête notamment en floride
et ça évidemment c'est un atout pour lui
parce qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
délégués répartis en floride la grande
question c'est la question de
vahan dit électorale aux états unis ça
veut dire est ce qui peut battre donald
trump l'équipe bad donald trump et là
ils sont pas d'accord du tout du côté de
sunderland il faut quelqu'un qui soit
capable de bouleverser un peu les choses
de remettre en cours d'établissement un
premier sondage dans l'histoire des
états unis on voit que les jeunes sont
d'accord avec le socialisme oui nous
sommes aux états unis socialisme
greening mais c'est le socialisme
démocratique à la sanders et puis de
l'autre côté on dit non il peut pas
c'est impossible de battre donald trump
avec un socialiste en tout cas comment
on va réconcilier ce parti ça c'est une
difficulté évidemment c'est un atout
pour dos d'un train avec mélenchon vous
l'avez rencontré leur descendance mais
non je suis pas encore allé aux états
unis certainement plus que de baden et
je suis très intéressé par la campagne
de sanders
on a étudié de près la dernière fois on
ya appris des choses je souhaite sa
victoire de toutes mes forces parce que
ça changerait l'histoire du monde
ensuite c'est un vrai bonheur de voir
naître aux états unis le droit de parler
de socialisme au sens où l'entend
senders bon il faut vous rendre compte
que le parti démocrate nord-américain
est la tête de file du mouvement social
démocrate mondiale la l'immense dérive
blairiste schrijder hollande et tout ça
c'est la famille clinton qu'il a
organisé cette droitisation de la social
démocratie qui a eu pour conséquence la
rupture avec les secteurs ouvriers qui
votait traditionnellement pour elle si
là elle s'effondre en allemagne chez le
s'effondre au danemark
c'est parce que les ouvriers 16 de voter
pour les sociaux-démocrates et votent
pour la droite nationaliste
donc monsieur byden ne peut pas battre
monsieur trump pas seulement parce qu'il
est maladroit après tout ça arrive à
tout le monde mais parce que il est
incapable de rallier à lui la classe
ouvrière américaine qui aujourd'hui fait
plus confiance à trump parce qu'elles
pensent que le nationalisme de trump va
protéger l'économie nord-américaine
caricaturé en disant il ya un candidat
des riches est un candidat des pauvres
parce que quand on regarde la sociologie
électorale avant les afro américains
votent pour bayonne ils sont pas
extrêmement rémois j'ai parlé et les
bien aimés et dans le vert menthe il
fait plutôt bien dans la classe ouvrière
donc c'est un peu plus complexe mais
simplement ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on parle aux etats unis
c'est que 74% des électeurs américains
aujourd'hui disent nous sommes
favorables à un impôt sur la fortune
ça c'est totalement nouveau dans
l'histoire en tout cas depuis que des
sondages et la saisie des deux
évidemment six ans donc de pardon de
vous contredire sur un point j'entends
moi je fais pas la caricature je pense
pas qu'ils aient un lien direct en
immédiat entre classes sociales et
représentation politique vous je me
serve que la social-démocratie le
courant du socialisme démocratique où le
mien en lui même n'a pas réalité ni
d'intérêt s'il n'est pas en phase avec
les salariés ceux qui votent dans les
primaires démocrates s&d démocrate
le problème c'est pas de trouver un des
démocrates j'ai d'avoir un candidat
démocrate qui convaincre des électeurs
radicalisé au point d'aller voter train
qui vaut mieux voter démocratie
c'est-à-dire s'énerve parce que lui va
améliorer leur sort pour convoyer
jackman est bien pris au maximum il
traduit hollande il faut réconcilier les
deux parties vous vous souvenez de 1972
ont fait tourner en boucle l'idée que mc
govern était trop à gauche pour gagner
mais c'était pas ça le problème c'est
qu'en 1972 le parti démocrate était très
divisée ben le coeur du cac on s'arrête
là jean luc mélenchon merci infiniment
d'être venu sur le plateau de lcp
merci à vous également pour pour ce
débat très belle soirée et à demain
[Musique]